okay so how did Andy Circus  play King Kong how'd you play King Kong  I played him on set with the Naomi Watts  um in a gorilla muscle suit  and I was on top I do have the gorilla  muscle suit at home and I was on top of  uh I was on top of cherry pickers and  cranes and so all sorts of adjustable  height ladders so that we could be uh in  close proximity to each other or I could  be at the right height and then I had a  thing called congolizer which was a  thing which then projected my voice  through these big speakers so I could  sounded like a big gorilla and then I  did and then I when all of that was  finished when we did the onset stuff and  we shot all of Naomi's side of things  then I went on to the motion capture  stage for two months and and did all of  uh Khan's movements so it was a complex  Affair it's kind of blowing my mind I  need to work with you on that kind of  stuff